[Music]
all right so the sick the twisted the
mentally unstable anti-trump media again
working itself into a new manufactured
frenzy now we have been explaining how
the bias press operates in this country
for a while here's how it works they
rush from one fabricated meltdown to
another and in the process these
brain-dead so-called journalists they
bounce around the same talking points in
their little fake news bubble
echo-chamber
and it becomes a competition to see well
who can say the most outlandish the most
offensive the most completely false
thing about President Trump it's like
they're hypnotized lobotomized robots
that kind of programmed every wake up
hey Trump it's really pathetic and it's
sad and it's predictable and they are
not serving you the American people now
members of the media sadly they're sheep
they're closed-minded they have actually
convinced themselves this is the
psychotic part through their own
conspiracy theories that President Trump
is oh he's suffering from dementia
he has early onset Alzheimers he's
deranged now the newest fake news
fixation is all about the president's
health think he'd be happy and naturally
after the president's doctor told them
that he was in excellent I repeat
excellent physical condition and the
shock time could easily serve for two
full terms the media media could not
believe it it goes against everything
they have all been telling themselves
hour after hour day after day week after
week month after month the press they
can't stand the fact that the president
scored a perfect 30 for 30 on a
cognitive exam and my guess is most of
the people in the media world would
probably fail that test if they took it
themselves I'd love to test them now
before we show you new examples it's
important to highlight just how utterly
insane the media was yesterday at the
press conference with the president's
doctor watch this do you keep a tally of
how much gold the US president plays
some of the president's friends have
told reporters in the past they think
he's a germaphobe that he washed his
hands obsessively and is concerned about
that do you see any indication
of that type of behavior do you see any
evidence of bone spurs which the
president said to be suffered from she
limited to one stood the rest for now
you know Twitter doesn't involve me as a
doctor I don't know I don't have any
concern on that does the president wear
dentures the president has no partial
ordinary dentures of any kind he has no
drug addiction this is real reporting
this question he went on for 49 straight
minutes the media just refused to face
the truth the reality President Trump is
perfectly healthy you'd think they would
be happy apparently not
of course it didn't take long for what
we're now calling Trump health truthers
think about this they come out in the
media and now they're questioning
everything that the doctor said this is
unbelievable watch this the alleged
excellent medical exam results the
fellow in the White House was spawned
and spawned a new conspiracy theory it's
known as the girth er he said he's an
excellent help but I mean Sanjay Gupta
came out was like sure about excellent
health he seemed like a Trump fanboy
when he said 239 pounds whatever but I
mean I know I'm being a guru but I mean
right if that's what 6-3 239 pounds
looks like it's a shock to me not sure
if it makes me feel better that this
doctor says that he has no cognitive
issues makes me feel worse and more
worried for the country the White House
press corps seemed stunned that the
president who cannot button the button
on his suit coat isn't much heavier the
Montreal cognitive assessment is
actually a fairly low level test it is
unbelievably good at predicting dementia
or pre dimension that doesn't say that
he's not morally or even mentally unfit
to be President it just says he doesn't
have pre dementia yeah we're gonna
really listen to dr. Joe liberal Joe and
dr. mica and by the way CNN they took
things even further with this morbid and
sad prediction this is nuts
about President Trump take a look this
coronary Kelsey
score is a score that a lot of
cardiologists use to try and be
predictive and be proactive and if the
number gets up over 100 that that is
concerning to a lot of doctors it's
concerning because you can start to say
well if you do nothing different if you
if things don't change you can start to
predict the likelihood of having some
sort of heart event cardiac event a
heart attack or something like that
within a certain number of years so the
president has heart disease those
numbers qualify him for having heart
disease and it clearly needs a plan to
try and prevent some sort of heart
problem down the road
really he's never examined the president
now we know that fake do CNN I have a
new name in a second then we know they
hate the president but really they're
gonna predict a guy that's never
examined the president that he's gonna
have a heart attack and this type of
behavior it shouldn't be surprising
especially coming from what we're now
calling you see it right there
CNN the whole network or the whole fake
news network
it fits CNN somehow managed to say that
word hundreds of times in one week alone
here are just a few of the examples I
promise I played them all I have too
much news to cover tonight but here's
some we'll put it on our website
tomorrow what was your reaction when you
heard the president called you know
African nations polls it's not clear
what he meant by both countries are you
shocked or surprised by this I'm not
surprised
in one way I'm proud I am a proud polar
know we are not all created equal
at least not if you are born in as the
president put it a whole country the
word house instead of whole as in house
countries not whole countries I guess
he's a baller is there a difference if
the president said whole house do you
think these countries are poles Donald
Trump has turned the Oval Office into
uh-oh
bowlers built this country a hundred and
ten years ago in addition of the
president for comments yesterday all
right a few more whole countries
hold pole country rich do you have an
example of any coal country that the
president referred to that is
predominantly Caucasian polish poles
coolers oh I work for polar
oh cool I'm proud to be a polar ever a
million years thought I would be saying
Bowl on television
congratulations see it and you've done
more than enough to earn your new
nickname the whole network fake news
network
keep up the good work now you would
think that CNN after hearing this over
and over and over again for the American
people what I'm about to play maybe they
would listen and say wow maybe we're not
doing something right here
take a look
[Applause]
they're not listening apparently they
are so hard-headed that nothing syncs it
all so tonight we have major breaking
news this is important tonight about the
phony fake news Hillary Clinton bought
and paid for Russian propaganda document
and dossier Sarah Carter reporting that
longtime Clinton aide advisor Sid
Vicious Blumenthal apparently was
interviewed by the FBI in 2016 about
this fake news anti-trump dossier and
that's not all according to the
Washington examiner's Byron York
congressional investigators are now
working to determine whether or not the
Obama State Department was involved in
gathering and circulating fictitious and
totally fake information that was found
in that dossier it's getting deeper
every night and according to another new
report an FBI agent exchanged
information about the bureau's Russia
investigation with the former spy that
was getting the phony Russian
information Christopher Steele he's the
guy that put the dossier together so you
have Steele being told by our FBI about
their Russia investigation at the same
time Steele is getting paid by Hillary
Clinton to dig up phony Russian
propaganda source dirt on Donald Trump
you can't make this up and we also know
from fusion GPS co-founder Glenn Simpson
his testimony that Steele briefed the
FBI about the dossier before the
election this is corruption at the
highest levels